I want to start at the beginning with
you I think you have a really
um a really interesting background and I
think your background is is particularly
interesting in light of what we're
looking at now in this country in terms
of freedoms being trampled on
so your family immigrated to the us when
you were 10. do I have that right okay
10 years old they fled Iran as refugees
what do you remember as a 10 year old
most about that time did you understand
the why of why your family was fleeing
yeah so we we talked about it as a
family my mom didn't want me to serve
the military there so we left that 10.
this is July of 89 we went to Germany
and Refugee you lived in a refugee camp
for a year and a half and it came here
November 28 1990 when I'm 12. so when
we're leaving nobody liked the war who
was very uncertain times it was you know
you you had no clue what was going to
happen the next day but also at the same
time my mom and dad were waiting since
84 to get a green card and finally my
mom's like no we got to get out of here
we can't stay here so my mom made the
decision my dad said no problem you guys
go to Germany I'll meet you guys in the
states we leave in a white Renault to
the airport we get on a Lufthansa
Lufthansa airline plane and we head out
when we crossed the Border they said you
cannot take down your scarves your hijab
and we can alcohol is now being served
I'll never forget that announcement wow
everyone starts clapping you know did
you understand what that means because
you're like what is it now everybody's
and then alcohol started coming and you
know the guys are bringing the stuff
over so no we knew listen it was a dream
every time in Iran somebody would either
go to Australia or would go to Spain or
Germany or us there was always a party
everybody would come together and party
that you're leaving of course the
biggest dream was coming to the states
coming to us but no we knew exactly why
we were leaving so I want to ask you why
the states then when you say the biggest
dream was coming here why there's only
one place they called you know the the
country's name follows by dream there is
no Australian Dream there is no Spanish
Spain dream or you know French Dream or
Russian Dream It's Only The American
Dream there's only one place that you
and I can say the American dream because
I can come here I can decide to live a
big life I can live a small life I can
be regular person I can be famous I can
be rich I can be poor I can choose to do
anything I want to do here of course if
I can not break the law I have a big
upside but you can be a Christian you
can be a Muslim you can be a
Scientologist you can be seven day you
can be an atheist you can be agnostic
you can be whatever you want to be here
nobody cares in America all the other
places they care not here so what do you
say to people who feel that the American
dream is dying who feel that it's under
attack whether it's from a business
angle whether it's from a freedom angle
whether it's from what's Happening to
kids around the country some feel that
there's a system in place call it a
system a matrix that's out to get the
little guy and they feel like the
American dream has been compromised
maybe Beyond repair what's your response
to that I think you're always going to
be a a under attack I think American
dream has been under attack since day
one because anytime you're a threat to
anybody you're gonna constantly have
attack meaning uh Walmart's always going
to be attacked by Amazon Amazon's always
going to be attacked by Walmart uh you
know Starbucks has to be worried about
coffee bean coffee beans got to be
worried about Starbucks the best
athletes have to be worried about
rookies coming and wanting to take their
Throne you know Dethrone them Tom
Brady's having a hard time stepping away
from the game I don't think he wants to
give it up to the next person so he's a
threat until somebody takes him out so
if if America was a sports team they're
number one worldwide and nobody likes
number one the only people that like
number one are the people that are on
the number ones team involved in growing
the number one team job creators doers
those who are going out there paying
taxes those who are going out there
making the society a better place they
like to see their team as being number
one the best they're creators but
sometimes those that are part of a team
that are not contributing they're
they're the ones that no one knows their
names because they don't want to get up
and do the work like some others are
doing they don't want to see that team
winning because it's almost like when
somebody uh you know breakup happens you
always want to see the X fail people
want people who are not contributing
towards America's success don't want to
see America succeed because America is
winning without them it's a form of
saying you're not needed we're gonna go
with or without you that's not the most
exciting feeling
to people who don't contribute but as as
far as America being under attack it's
always been under attack and it's always
going to be under attack that's a very
normal place to be when you're number
one if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one face
time with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
minute right now click right here and
let's get talking
foreign
[Music]